il a besoin d'exploiter quelqu'un pas
quelqu'un que tu n'aimes même pas certains
la compagnie de téléphone vous appelle
ça te dérange juste de dire
note doit être évalué trafiquant de drogue je fais le
mer
disons la conclusion la fellation qui
[Musique]
même avec l'effe spaccio et l'amour spaccio
tsm tout avait mais le grand cesse
landes de terrorisme après la crise italienne
[ __ ] de merde l'âme du kit est
décédé
le sachet de trabucchi maman l'a essayé
que dans l'action à accomplir
mais merci les grandes fêtes
maman nous devons la remercier
mère parce qu'elle t'a mis au monde
et nous devons souffrir sa présence
omni merde une manière aussi un peu ancienne
dire à une mauvaise personne que
une telle alliance
[Musique]
le vrai sang est un connard jette une photo
reste comme ça maman désolé